bonjour eric zemmour bonjour vous
souhaitiez revenir sur une personnalité
qui vient de mourir du coronavirus le
sénateur l'ancien sénateur socialiste
henri weber
c'est un parcours passionnant à un jeune
homme trotskiste qui fait la révolution
en mai 68 et qui devient un notable de
la république bat personnes parcourent
en hommes et en même temps parcours
emblématique c'est à dire que parcours
hors norme parce que le type est un
enfant d'immigré au juif polonais né au
tadjikistan
car il en france qui fait les une
brillante envoyée il ya le côté
romantique du du fils d'immigré qui
arrive à une position sociale
extraordinaire et il y a en même temps
quelque chose de tout à fait classique
tout à fait emblématique c'est à dire
cette gauche qui est passé entre les
années 60 et les années 90 de trotsky à
fabius et dominique strauss kahn
oui pour pour pour pour résumer
l'histoire de deux henri weber et de ce
il est passé de la révolution communiste
à la révolution libérale pour vous il ya
pourtant une cohérence dans ce parcours
d'henri weber de trotsky à dominique
strauss kahn et ce fil conducteur c'est
l'internationalisme alors je trouve
alors il a oui je cherchais je vous
avoue parce que je le connais depuis
longtemps c'est un garçon très
sympathique vous savez c'est à dire
qu'ils aimaient la joute oratoire et qui
n'avait pas ce qui est vraiment très
ennuyeux chez la plupart des gens de
gauche cette espèce de sectarisme
moralisateur voiliers qui qui qui vous
fait passer pour un mécréant et e pour
un un grand prêtre de la religion de
l'humanité
il n'avait pas ça alors en compensation
il avait une espèce de cynisme
gouailleur mais on peut pas tout avoir
mais donc gelé bien connu il est bien un
seul affronter plusieurs fois en débat
et ce qui m'a marqué c'est que on peut
croire que toute sa vie n'a été que
palinodies puisque je vous dis il est
passé de de la révolution communiste
trotskiste à la révolution libérale de
de l'empiré soviétique à l' empire
européen occidental riom on pourrait y
voir des contradictions majeures et
elles le sont mais si on y réfléchit
bien il y à un fil rouge c'est
l'internationalisme c'est le refus des
nations et des peuples
c'est cette volonté de mondialiser 7
brillé alors au nom de l'humanisme au
nom du progrès au nom de tout ce que
vous voulez mais il y à cette
détestation des peuples et des nations
qui faisait que moi je ne m'étais jamais
d'accord avec lui
voyez mais je pense que c'est le fil
rouge de ces gens là en fait henri weber
n'est qu' un exemple de ces jeunes gens
qui était à l'époque très à gauche ou
très à droite et pour qui mai 68 a été
une forme de tremplin politique
d'ascenseur social
ah oui tout à fait il ya une photo
absolument magnifique qui avait été
publiée dans france soir je crois si je
ne dis pas de bêtises juste avant mai 68
300 sont en fait où on voit henri weber
superbe 20 ans jeune beau avec un apéro
couvert d'un imperméable blanc avec une
barre de fer à la main et qui va pour
affronter justement ce qu'il appelait à
l'époque les fachos et qui était vous
avez tout à fait raison
alain madelin patrick devedjian un autre
mordu coronavirus d'ailleurs le mot
allah gérard longuet alain robert est
effectivement on a cet affrontement
entre l'extrême gauche et l'extrême
droite comme on disait à l'époque et qui
fait que tous ces gens vont ils prendre
un ascenseur social fantastique mais
c'est très français
on a vu ça pour la révolution de 89 on a
vu ça pour la révolution de 1830 on a vu
ça pour la révolution de 1848 donc
c'était toute l'histoire de france qui
est comme ça on monte par la politique
et après tout bon appartement par la
politique pas seulement par les guerres
donc c'est toute l'histoire de france
depuis deux siècles qui se poursuivait
la par mai 68 merci eric zemmour